[Music]  there's a lot of olympic spirit right  out there in the country in america  right now and well someone on our staff  though isn't as excited he thinks that  some people may have gone a little  overboard in their enthusiasm about the  olympics here to explain is one of our  writers mr dion cole  thanks conan i am glad everyone is  enjoying the olympics but i noticed  something yesterday that bothered me  yesterday on the google search site it  was dedicated at home screen to the  olympic runners and they had a cartoon  of an image of a black guy running take  a look  no big deal to you all right  well to me it looked like a black man  running on watermelon  but if that wasn't enough look at what  google put on their site today  a chicken relay race  i can't wait to see what they come up  with tomorrow  [Applause]